it is Friday once again which means I'm
here to cover you up on five of the
biggest things that happened in gaming
this week let's get into it
Warner Brothers landed themselves in hot
water this wake when sources told kotaki
that the publisher were aware of issues
with the PC version of Batman Arkham
Knight for months according to Kotaku
the source is indicated that Warner
Brothers did not properly QA the PC
version and that Rocksteady was not the
primary developer instead it appears the
majority of the PC development fell to
iron galaxy Studios Rocksteady also
opted not to run the PC version through
typical PC stress testing firms because
they didn't want the game's plot to
spoil allegedly the QA process only
allocated around a dozen people to both
checking the PC version and the internal
team only focused on bugs checking at
720p on top of that according to the
sources Deb's would fix what they could
but will primarily occupied at least
finishing the game
this week's witcher 3 dlc have dropped
mg of which you'll get to the low low
price of free the dlc contains a new
quest entitled that where the cat and
the wolf play the official description
says explore a forgotten village and
discover its terrifying secret find out
who or what slaughtered its inhabitants
and use all your witch's skills to
confront this mysterious force the
latest winter 3 game update will also
add a new witch a contract in our two
village where you'll be asked to face
off against a mysterious foe called a
spook this week's offering marks number
15 of the 16 planned add-ons and two
major paid expansions are still to come
last week I gave you the latest on which
Xbox games you can grab for free with
your subscription this month but now for
those of you on PlayStation here's the
PS plus games you can pick up in July
the main edition you guys seem pretty
excited about this month is soccer plus
vehicles game rocket league which Sony
are giving you for free on ps4 and will
support cross-platform play with the PC
Edition across ps4 ps3 and PlayStation
Vita you can pick up in twine and mouse
craft additionally on ps4 you can get
six master shadows here three players
will be able to play the lovely looking
brain and those of you of the Vita will
get to try their hand at geometry Ward 3
does this Pete Hines have come out to
say that the company had to be very
careful about how they were going to
announce mobile game fallout shelter
times explained if we tried to do this
last year without announcing what
bethesda game studios was doing or
referencing fallout 4 and said oh we're
doing a game and it's on verbal and it's
called fallout shelter we'd probably get
lynched right mine said the telling game
is full out shelter existed and that
they could play it as soon as it was
announced may have contributed to its
success hein said Bethesda has plans to
potentially add new content to fallout
shelter but that for the moment they're
just pleased with how it's doing
the infamous predator isn't coming from
Mortal Kombat X until next week but a
bunch of info has already landed an
extensive leak which came via Xbox user
sonic 220th included a bunch of videos
showing predator and Carl Weathers also
known as Apollo Creed from rocky as
Jack's we got a look at multiple
finishing moves and combo berry ations
event hubs also dropped a bunch of new
details which highlighted predators
fatality brutality and gory wind pose
predator is the third DLC character to
be released for the game following Jason
Voorhees and Tania and will be available
on July 7 with the combat packs e-zpass
let me know in the comments what you
cared about this week and if you're keen
for the selection of playstation plus
games for July this week on site I go
over five awesome III trailers you may
have missed out on on the ships
blue sea covers off on gaming biggest
backstabbers on in
minute and the lobby asks if destiny is
exploiting its players that is
everything I've got for you this week as
always let me know what you cared about
have an awesome 4th of July weekend
and I'll catch you again on Monday